[Music]
ASAP Rocky is Rihanna's biggest fan
during her Super Bowl halftime show I'm
still pinching myself really I'm
grateful I'm grateful that's the rapper
caught on cam proudly cheering on his
lady love while she performed all her
biggest hits
[Music]
[Applause]
ahead of the show a source showed E.T
Rocky and their son whom he and
re-welcomed last May planned to be by
Rihanna's side Rocky's been very
supportive throughout her preparation
and stepped up his parenting game while
she was busy with rehearsals the Super
Bowl is one of the biggest stages in the
world yeah and Riri took that moment to
reveal she and Rocky are expecting baby
number two
another source says Rihanna adores being
a mom and it's her biggest
accomplishment her and ASAP have always
wanted to grow their family being a mom
is a dream come true she takes so much
pride in it what are you looking forward
to As you move into a new chapter of
your life ASAP I'm just excited for what
I don't know yet you know everything is
new to me so you know I'm excited and
Riri recently shared with Nate Burleson
how motherhood has changed her life I
would like to ask who is Rihanna living
for oh
are you kidding my son
my son my son my son my son everything
matters now you you you really start to
take a lot into account you know like
skydiving might go on the bathroom like
you really think about stuff like that
right it's like it's not it's not worth
it congrats to Rihanna and Rocky on
their growing families
foreign